[Música]
la oferta educativa de quebec es de muy
alta calidad y viene a un precio a un
costo que es sumamente competitivo el
francés como lengua de aprendizaje de
estudios así como lengua de trabajo en
el futuro es una ventaja competitiva
para una persona así que estudiar en
quebec ofrece muchos muchas ventajas
además de la calidad de vida la
seguridad cuando uno está estudiando
allá pero también para uno dice moss un
bagaje profesional para un joven que va
a estudiar en quebec y que regresa con
unas herramientas con una educación de
muy alta calidad un alto nivel de
francés esto le va a apoyar durante toda
su carrera lo que tiene que saber es que
hay unos pasos que se tienen que seguir
para estudiar en que ve que no son tan
complicados pero uno tiene que pensarlo
bien y todo esto proceso este proceso
normalmente lleva de 8 a 9 meses así que
tiene que pensar con anticipación y de
pie en preparar la cola